Everyone knows that if you're not using
an AI coding assistant, you are going to
fall behind no matter what you are
developing. But what people usually
don't know is how to use these AI coding
assistants effectively. I mean, sure,
you can't just throw whatever you want
at an AI IDE like Windsurf or Cursor,
and sometimes you'll get good results,
but if you don't have a clear process
for working with them, that is
definitely not the case all the time.
And it is so frustrating when the LLM
goes from a senior software engineer to
what seems like a pack of primates
mashing on a keyboard, deleting parts of
your code, implementing features that
you don't want, you know the pain. And
you have to have a well- definfined
process when using AI to code if you
want highquality outputs and you want
them consistently. And if you don't have
that refined process yet, I promise you
that by the end of this video, you'll be
at a whole new dimension of developing
with AI, cuz I'm going to walk you
through my full workflow step by step
and just get into those nitty-gritty
details so you can just copy my process
to 10x, even 100x your productivity when
developing with AI. And to make this
well worth your time, there are three
things that I'm going to promise to you.
The first is that we're not going to
over complicate our setup, which I see
people do a lot with AIDS. The second
thing is we're not just building a toy.
We're going to use this workflow to
build a full practical and useful
example with a superbase MCP server.
More on that in this video. And then the
third thing is that this process is
going to work for you no matter what you
are developing or which AI IDE you are
using. Last thing really quick. If you
want to level up more than just your AI
coding workflow, but your AI skills as a
whole, I have the perfect thing for you.
Check out dynamis.ai. It's an exclusive
community that I just launched the
weight list for. It's where I take my
expertise that I bring to you constantly
on YouTube to a much deeper level with
courses, live workshops, weekly
sessions, daily support, and the best
part, a community for you to join with
other early AI adopters. So check out
the link, join the weight list, and with
that, let's dive into our full process
for coding with AI. So what you're
looking at here is a Google doc, which
I'll link to in the description of this
video, that gives my full process of
coding with AI. So use this as a
resource for yourself. We're going to be
referencing this constantly throughout
the video as well because this is
everything. This is our full process,
starting with the golden rules at the
top. So, I'll cover these quick and then
we'll see how they really dictate a lot
of the rest of our process starting with
step number two where we'll go into
actually starting our project. And so,
the very first golden rule, this one's
super important. We want to use these
higher level markdown documents that
have instructions for installation,
documentation, planning, and tasks. Use
these to give context to our LLM. And so
we're going to be creating and managing
these using AI to help throughout the
creation of our project. And then the
next three rules here are all about not
overwhelming the LLM because the longer
context you give to an LLM, the more
likely it is to hallucinate. And so, for
example, you want to keep all of your
code files under 500 lines. You want to
start fresh conversations often because
longer conversations can really bog down
an LLM. And then also, you don't want to
overwhelm the LLM by asking it to do too
many things at the same time. In fact, I
usually find that it's best to just ask
it to do one new feature or implement
one new thing per prompt that I give it.
Much better results. If you have really
long files, long conversations, you're
asking for a lot of things at the same
time, that's when you start to get
terrible results no matter which LLM or
AI IDE you are using. And then also, not
everyone likes tests. Most people don't.
But it's very important to ask the AI to
write tests for its code. Ideally, after
every new feature that it implements,
and that's how you really get consistent
output. Also, be specific with your
requests. And so, this is where it's
actually better to provide a little bit
of extra context. And so, you don't want
to overwhelm the LLM, but you also don't
want it to be left to its own devices.
You want to be very specific with what
you're looking for. Like don't just
describe what you want to build at a
high level, but get into the details of
the technologies that you want it to
use, the different libraries, what you
want the output to look like. Be
specific and that helps a lot as well.
And then the last two rules here, write
docs and comments as you go. You want
the LLM to constantly be updating
documentation both in these uh you know
higher level core files, but also
comments in the code as well. that helps
both yourself to understand what it's
doing and also itself as it references
these files in later conversations. And
then the very last thing is to implement
environment variables yourself. Do not
trust the LLM with your API keys and
securing your database, all that good
stuff, because you do not want to be
this guy. I put this link in here cuz I
just thought it was really funny. This
is an example of what can go seriously
wrong when you vibe code. This guy built
his full SAS with Cursor. He didn't do
any of the coding and he's all hyped
here. This is March 15th. He's like, "AI
is not just an assistant. It's the
builder now." But then look at this. Two
days later, he gets hacked. Random
things are happening. Maxed out usage on
API keys, people bypassing
subscriptions, probably because he
didn't have correct database security.
All these things going wrong because he
trusted AI to manage his environment
variables, his database security, all of
the things around security. You have to
make sure you understand yourself. And
really, you should understand all the
code that AI is producing. I generally
don't recommend vibe coding, but even if
you do vibe code, at least make sure
that you understand if your project is
secure or not. That is super important.
And so, with all these golden rules out
of the way, we'll see these constantly
throughout the rest of this document,
let's get into starting our project,
beginning with our planning. So, for the
planning phase, it's pretty simple. We
just want to create our planning and
task files. And we're going to do this
before we're even getting into any
coding at all because we want to have
that higher level direction before we
write a single line of code. And so our
planning document, this is where we have
the highle vision, architecture,
constraints, all of these highlevel
pieces of information that we want to
give as context to the LLM. And we can
ask the LLM, the AI coding assistant
throughout the process to reference this
file, which is especially useful at the
beginning of new conversations so it can
quickly get up to speed with everything
that we're doing in our project. So it
doesn't have to analyze different code
files to figure that out itself. And
then at a slightly lower level, we have
the task markdown file. This is where we
track all of our tasks, things that have
been done and still need to be done. And
throughout the conversation, we can have
the LLM update and create new tasks,
delete tasks, mark them as done, all
that good stuff. And that really allows
us to be the project manager for the AI
coding assistant, which is important
because we want to dictate everything
that it does. And this is just a
resource for us to do that well and have
the AI coding assistant help in that
process, too. And so for creating these
files, I usually don't even do this in
an AI IDE. I'll just use a chatbot like
Claw Desktop for example. And so I have
this sample prompt right here for the
Superbase MCP server that we want to
create. And so we're using MCP as a
connector. So we can use apps like Claw
Desktop, our own AI agents to connect to
Superbase so that it has tools to do
things in our database. And so for the
planning for this, I'm just telling it
to use the Brave API because I have the
Brave MCP server set up. I'm not going
to get into a ton of details on this
because that's kind of outside of the
scope of this video. Just use this as an
example for very quickly asking it to
plan both the planning.md and task.md
files. And so I'll send in this prompt
and then it'll search the web for me. So
I'll allow it to do that and then let me
come back once it has created both of
these files. And there we go. Claw
desktop created both files for me. And
it did it right there in my file system
because I have the MCP server for that
too. So it made him right here in this
directory. So I can open that up in
Windsurf which you can use any AI coding
assistant. Just keep that in mind. I'm
using Windsurf but this will work with
cursor client root code. It doesn't
matter. This process applies to all. And
here we have our planning file. So I'm
going to need to open this preview here
and take a look at this. We have our
overview. We have the project scope, the
technical architecture, technology
stack, all these things that we can now
give as context to the AI coding
assistant when it starts the project to
make sure that it's starting on the
right foot. This is certainly not a
perfect document. Like I wouldn't really
want a what is MCP and what is superbase
section. We don't really care about
that. And so I'm going to edit this off
camera and just save you the boring
details here. But this is a good
starting point. And typically you will
want to iterate on this quite a bit
within the chatbot or wherever you're
working on this file. And then we've got
our tasks as well. So I can open a
preview for this. We can see all the
different tasks that it set up for us.
And we'll have the AI coding assistant
knock these out one by one and add new
ones as necessary as well. And this is
pretty overkill. So again, you're going
to want to iterate on these thing. Like
we don't need that many tasks for this.
This is pretty crazy. Um but yeah, I
mean this is a good starting point. One
last tip that I want to give on the
planning phase, something I like to do a
lot is instead of just using a single
LLM like Claude, I want to use multiple
different large language models to help
me plan my project. So, I'll just give
the same prompt to each of them and then
combine everything at the end. Now, the
trick is you have to have a good
platform that can help you work with
these different LLMs in one place
without having to pay multiple
subscriptions. And there are a lot of
different apps out there for that. But
one of my favorites that is sponsoring
this video, but I do use them a lot is
Global GPT because they're very
affordable. You can get started for free
with access to all the best LLMs like
Deepseek and 03 and Claude. And they
even have tools added in like Deep
Research or Perplexity for example. If
you really want to go deep in your
planning, you can do that with Global
GPT. And there's a lot of other tools as
well, like if you wanted to use
ideoggram or midjourney to help you plan
your assets for your project as well.
You can do all of that. So, you're going
to have an interface that's very similar
to Claude Desktop like we just saw, but
just being able to access these
different LLMs very easily, do things
like deep research. And so, yeah,
definitely use a platform like this if
you want to really dive deep in your
planning for your project. So, I'll have
a link in the description to Global GPT.
Definitely recommend checking them out.
But yeah, that's just the last quick tip
that I wanted to give for planning your
projects. Now, let's get into the next
phase. Now that we have the planning and
tasks done, it's time to move on to
global rules. This is essentially system
prompts for your AI coding assistant.
So, all the high-level instructions that
you want to give to the AI coding
assistant, you do in the global rules so
you don't have to type it out explicitly
every time. Like for example in our
global rule we can say always read the
planning file at the start of a new
conversation. So that way when we start
the conversation ourselves we don't have
to explicitly ask it to do so. And so it
saves you from typing a lot on all your
different requests because instead of
saying please implement this and then
write tests and then check off the task,
you can just tell it to do so in the
global rules like check the tasks, make
sure you write your tests for all your
new features. We have that all now as
kind of a system prompt to the LLM. This
is the global rule that I have set up in
my AI coding assistant. You can use this
yourself. Tweak it to your needs
depending on your technology stack and
any other requirements that you have.
But yeah, this is a really good starting
point for you. And then I even have
instructions for the four most popular
AI idees how you can get this set up.
And so specifically, let me copy this.
I'll show you how to do it in Windsurf
because that's just the AI IDE I'm using
in this video. I'll copy this and then
I'll go over to Windsurf and then you
click on the additional options in the
top right manage memories and then you
have your global rules. This is going to
apply no matter what directory you're
in. And then you have workspace specific
rules. So if you want to have rules for
just your current project, you set it up
here. Typically, it's recommended to
have workspace rules because a lot of
times different things like the
technologies that you're asking it to
use are going to be specific to that
project. And so, I would typically
recommend workspace rules. So, we can go
into here and then just paste in
everything that we copied from the
Google doc. And then I can just like my
other markdown files, I can open up a
preview and see that we have now have
these rules set up for the AI coding
assistant. So, we tell it how to use
these different markdown files. This is
how without having to always ask it to
look at planning and mark off tasks in
the prompts on the right hand side,
it'll still know how to work with these
files. And then we tell it about some of
our other golden rules like don't create
files that are longer than 500 lines. We
tell it about creating tests for each of
the features. Um, and then we give it
some style guidelines as well to make
sure that the code is clean that it
produces. We tell it how to work with
the readme file so it can maintain
documentation. And then at the bottom, I
like to have a bunch of kind of
miscellaneous rules to help it as well.
So that is our rules as a whole. And now
we can keep our prompts to the LLM quite
simple because we have all these
different things we're trying to have it
do and make sure it's following, but we
don't have to ask it each time. Now,
that's the important part with global
rules. So, we've got our global rule set
up now. Should have just taken you a
couple of minutes. Now, we can move on
to configuring our MCP servers. So, if
you are not familiar with MCP, I would
highly recommend checking out this video
that I linked to above where I did a
comprehensive overview, but really it's
just a way to give more tools to our AI
IDE so it can do things like search the
web with Brave. So, these are the core
three servers that I always use that
I'll go over in a bit. I've got links to
install each of them. I've got
instructions for how to set up MCP in
your different AIDes and even a link
here to a list of other MCP servers. You
can go here and download any other ones
that you might want to include. You can
click into any of these links to see
exactly how to set it up within your AI
IDE. So, it gives the instructions for
setting up your configuration. So, the
core three servers that I always use, I
want my AI IDE to be able to interact
with the file system, not just the
current project, but other folders on my
computer as well. Like maybe I have an
image folder. I want it to be able to
pull assets into the project from that.
or I want it to reference other projects
to learn how I did something previously.
I can do all of that when I have the
file system server. And then I also want
my AI IDE to be able to search the web.
And some AI idees have web search baked
in. But the Brave API is very powerful
in the way that it actually uses AI
under the hood to summarize a bunch of
the different web search results. So you
get some really powerful output. You can
use this to do things like pull
documentation for tools, libraries or
frameworks that you are using. And then
the last one that I really like using is
Git. And the reason for this is you
should really set up every project as a
Git repository. So you have version
control. You can manage backups of your
projects, have different versions that
are all saved. And so with the git MCP
server, you can do something like this
example prompt that I have here where
you say like, okay, I like where we're
at right now, and before I implement
more features, I want to really have a
backup of the current state. So please
make a git commit to save the current
state, which by the way, this is
something that I highly highly recommend
doing because sometimes you can go five
requests, 10 requests to an AI IDE. It
implements all these things and you
realize that it completely broke the
project five requests ago. So if you
have backups along the way, you can
revert to a working state. Otherwise,
sometimes you'll get into this state of
hell where your project is totally
broken, but you've gone too far and you
can't really go back. And so Git is your
savior for that. So that's why I love
using this server so much. And then
also, if you want to have more like
long-term memory, implement rag within
your AI IDE, you have a lot of other
tools. For example, the Quadrant MCP
server. So, I'm not going to get into
that cuz a lot of AI idees like Windsurf
already have memories. Like I can go in
here and manage memories and it can
generate those for me. I just have a
blank slate right now, but you can ask
it to keep track of memories between
projects and stuff. So, might not need
something like this, but there's still
great MCP servers anyway. So, yeah, get
all these set up. In my case, let me go
back over to Windsurf here, and I'll
open up my configuration. You just click
on configure MCP right here. And I have
this MCP config.json. So yeah, you can
see I have my file system, Brave Search,
Git, and then this is kind of out of the
scope of this video, but I have Archon,
which is my AI agent builder that I have
baked into Windinsurf as well. So I set
up all these servers. Just follow the
instructions that I have laid out right
here in this document. So get your MCP
set up and then use those as I describe
throughout your project and it's going
to help you a lot. So now it is time to
give that initial prompt to the AI IDE
to start our project because we have our
MCP servers configured, our global rules
set up and we have those planning and
task documents created. And like I call
out here, even though we have these
documents that give those higher level
details to the AI, we still want to be
very specific with our initial prompt
because that determines the entire
starting point for our project and that
is one of our golden rules to be very
detailed in what we are looking for. And
so this can mean a lot of different
things depending on your project. But
the key piece of advice that I have here
is to give a lot of documentation and
examples to the AI coding assistant. And
there are three different ways that we
can provide examples and documentation.
The first one is that a lot of AI idees
have built-in features for pulling in
documentation. For example, in Windsurf,
I can type at MCP and then hit tab. And
that's going to now include the MCP
documentation in the prompt to the LLM.
So it'll use rag under the hood to
search through the documentation and use
that to augment its answer. You can do
something very similar in other AI idees
like cursor as well. The other option
you have is using the Brave MCP server
or any other MCP server that you set up
for web search. So you can ask it to you
know go through the internet find
documentation for whatever libraries or
tools you are using like for example
search the web to find other MCP server
implementations or documentation. So you
can pull examples and docs this way or
just provide them manually like in this
example prompt that I have that we're
going to be using to create the
superbase MCP server. I'm just giving it
a link to a GitHub repo that has an
already existing implementation of a
Python MCP server. So it's using this
example kind of as documentation along
with I call out the documentation for
MCP and superbase at the top here. And
so this is an example prompt that is
very specific to what I am creating
here. But use this just as a template
for you. You want to call out
documentation, give examples, be very
specific in what you want it to build
and then you're going to get much better
results than just saying something super
bland like build a superbase MCP server.
So, we're going to take this prompt, go
into Windsurf. I already have this
entered in. So, I'm going to go ahead
and send this in, and we'll watch it
rip. And for example, I'm not even
calling out the planning.md file
anywhere in this prompt. But it's still
going to reference that after it pulls
the documentation for MCP and Superbase
because we have that called out in the
project level rules, those global rules
that we set for just this workspace. And
so, first it's looking through the
GitHub example I gave it. It's going
through the documentation. It's using
the Brave web search to get Superbase
Python client documentation. It's doing
a lot here. And this is taking a lot of
flow action. So, a lot of credits being
spent here, but it's important to have
the best starting point you can. And so,
generally, I'm okay with having it do
quite a bit at the start here. And you
can always prompt it to not do as much.
Um, and so I'm going to let it go
through all of this documentation
searching here, and then I'll come back
once it's moved on to the next step. All
right, so it's finished looking through
all the documentation. Now, look at
that. Boom. We're moving on to analyzing
the planning and tasks files. So, it's
pulling in all of that extra context.
And then, for some reason, it wants to
create a directory, I guess. Yeah, it's
planning to write the tests already. I
mean, this is good. It's following that
global rule as well. So, we'll let it
create that directory. Like, there we
go. Superbase mcpests.
And now it's moving on to coding up
everything. So it starts with the
requirements.ext and then I assume it'll
get into creating Yep, there we go. The
server.py. And this will take a little
bit because there's going to be a good
amount of code that goes into this. So
what I'm going to do here is pause and
come back once it has implemented the
first iteration of my server. And there
we go. Windsurf created the full
superbase MCP server for us in a single
prompt. And this is not a basic
implementation. It's almost 300 lines of
code and it looks really good. We've got
the ability to delete records, update
records, we can create records. And then
last, we have a tool to read rows in a
table. And this very much shows that
Windinsurf understood the MCP
documentation. Like even the way that it
sets up the Superbase client and defines
all of our tools. It very much read
through documentation, synthesized that
with our markdown files for planning and
tasks to create this beautiful piece of
code. And if we go into the tasks
markdown file, take a look at this. It
marked off the tasks as complete. It
didn't make any tests or update the
readme, which I kind of wish it did. It
made the tests folder, but then didn't
write tests, which is kind of strange. I
mean, you get weird behavior like that
sometimes where it it understands the
global rules, but doesn't do everything
you would want. But that's okay cuz
we'll just do that in a follow-up
prompt, and I'll show you that in a
second. But first, let's actually test
this and see if it's working. So, we
have this MCP server created locally
now. And I do want to make a dedicated
video on creating MCP servers, by the
way. So let me know in the comments if
you're interested in that. I'm going to
kind of gloss over the implementation
and running this right now because the
point of this video is to show my
process for coding with AI, not making
an MCP server. So anyway, in cloud
desktop here, I'm going to hook in the
server. So you just go to the top left,
file, settings, developer, and then you
click on edit config. It'll open the
configuration folder. We can go to the
cloudmcpconfig.json.
JSON file which I have open right here
in windsurf. So this is where I have all
of my servers set up for cloud desktop
specifically. And so to add in superbase
I just added in this line right here or
I have the command to my Python
executable specifically in the virtual
environment that I created. And again
these details aren't super important for
this video. I'll do a follow-up one for
making a server. Then we have the
arguments which just points to the
server that Windsurf just created for
me. And then for my environment, I'm
passing in what I have redacted here,
but I'm passing in my URL and service
key from Superbase. And so with all of
that there, you just have to restart
Cloud Desktop. And then if you open up
your MCP tools that are available, let
me scroll down to the first Superbase
one. Yeah, here we go. So create table
records. So we have this and then
there's the three other tools that we
have, which I'd be able to find if I
just scroll through the list of tools
here. And so now I can ask it something
like um what records do I have in my
document meta data table? This is a
table from a different video on my
channel with some rag stuff in N8N. And
so it's now going to call the superbase
tool. I'll allow for this chat. Okay, I
just did one prompt. I did not do
anything for follow-up prompting yet.
And look at this. We just one-shotted a
Superbase MCP server with Windsurf with
this strategy. And this would not be
possible if it wasn't for the rules that
I have and having it search through
documentation, giving it an example. All
of that together is what made this
possible. And I'm I'm actually blown
away. It this was a big implementation
for it to oneot. And it did that
successfully. These are indeed the
records that I have in this documents
metadata table in Superbase, which is
super cool. Okay, so now at this point,
we have a good state of our MCP server
that we want to save with git. so we can
revert back to it if we encounter any
issues down the line where the AI IDE
breaks things as we're adding a readme,
maybe tweaking the functionality of our
server or adding our tests. And so I'll
go into a new conversation here and I'll
tell it to uh make a git repo for this
project and make a commit. And so you
can either use the git mcp server or you
can just use a lot of these AI idees
have native commands that support
working with git repositories. And so
for example in this case it tried to use
a tool and failed for some reason. So
now it's just using the git status here
in the terminal and that works as well.
So you can use either. And so yep it
looks like there is a git repo that's
initialized. I was trying to run this
earlier. I ran it once before which is
why it already made the git repo. So now
it's making the git ignore which looks
good. We definitely want to have that.
And now it's doing the get add command.
Looks good. And again, you could use the
git mcp server for this as well. Um, but
I'm just using the commands. So I run
the status. And then now finally, it's
going to make a commit. And so there we
go. Boom. We make a commit. And now
everything that we have is saved. And so
we can ask it later to revert back to
this commit if it messes up anything.
And we want to just go to this current
state. And so with that done, now we can
move on to the next step where we want
to create tests and do some things that
it missed out on like creating the
readme as well. And that brings us back
to our main document because we're going
to knock out steps number six and seven
at the same time. Step number six goes
through what it looks like to iterate on
our project after the initial prompt.
And the important thing that it covers
here is that golden rule to only ask for
one change at a time. I've got a good
example of that and a very bad example.
The important thing is to not overwhelm
the LLM with your requests. And so in
our case, we know there are a couple of
things that we want to implement right
away. We want to create that readme, the
project documentation, because it didn't
do that at first for some reason. But
then the other thing that we want to
knock out right away, this just brings
us right to section number seven is we
want to create tests for that initial
version of our Superbase MCP server. And
so we'll just ask the LLM to create unit
tests for each of the tools that it made
in the server. And I outlined best
practices here for testing. These are
the things that we want to give to the
LLM, which you can just do in the global
rules. And so in this template that I
gave for you for the global rules,
everything that we saw in that section
for best practices for testing, I just
list out right here for the LLM. So you
don't even have to understand exactly
what mocking is, for example. You can
still give that as a rule to the LLM
because we want to have a dedicated
directory for our tests. We want to mock
calls to our database and LLM so we're
not using it for real because we want
our tests to be fast and free. And then
we also want to test a successful
scenario, make sure we're handling
errors properly in a test. And then a
edge case as well. And so we just
include all of that as global rules. And
so back over in windsurf now I can just
have a new conversation up and I can ask
it to create tests for server.py in and
then I can just call out the test
directory that I already have right
here. Um it looks like there's way too
many directories here. So I'm just going
to delete that at and say in the tests
and so boom there we go. And I could be
way more explicit here and it's probably
helpful to provide some more
instructions, but remember because of
the global rules, it's going to follow
those best practices without me doing
anything in the prompt related to it.
And so I can be very simple here. And so
yeah, what I'm going to do is pause and
come back once it is done creating those
initial tests for me. All right,
windsurf created all of the tests for
our server. And there was an issue
initially where 12 of the tests were
passing and then two were unsuccessful.
So I went through a little bit of an
iteration there just with a couple of
follow-up prompts. But after that it is
working beautifully. So now in my
terminal I can just run the command pi
test and then I just reference my test
folder right here from the root
directory. And look at this 14 tests and
they all pass. and it's 14 because we're
testing a successful failure and edge
case scenario for each of our different
tools. And then I guess a couple of
extras as well to do things like test
the lifespan with the environment
variables. And this is super
comprehensive. Like this file is
massive, almost 500 lines of code. And
that's generally what your testing files
are going to look like. Sometimes
they're longer than the base file itself
just because you want to hit on all
those different scenarios. And so yeah,
these are really solid tests and
everything is mocked. This is beautiful.
And so now at this point, we have our
first version of the Superbase MCP
server. It's working. We tested it in
cloud desktop. We've got unit tests.
Everything is good. Now we can move on
to iterating things as we want. We can
also create a readme file. All the while
making sure that we are keeping our
tasks and planning markdown files up to
date because again that's that all
important context that we need
especially if we are starting new
conversations. Then there are a lot of
other things that we'll want to do to
iterate on our superbase MCP server.
I'll just do that off camera though
because at this point I've already
demonstrated this entire workflow. The
very last step that we have here is
deploying our project. Because once
you're at a state with what you're
building where you want to deploy it,
package it up to ship it to the cloud,
share with other people, you can do that
with the AI coding assistant as well.
And my favorite way to do it is through
Docker or another similar service like
Podman. And the best part is LLM are
very good at working with Docker just
because it's been around for so long.
There's so many examples of it on the
internet that's been used to train the
LLMs. And so they can help you create a
docker file to package up and deploy
your application even including giving
you the commands to use as well. And so
like this is an example prompt that I
have here. Just write a docker file for
this MCP server using the
requirements.ext file for all of the
Python requirements. Give me the
commands to build the container after.
And so I did that already. I didn't want
to bore you with the details of waiting
for this to complete. So I created this
docker file to package up the MCP
server. And then I also had it create
the readme in a separate command because
remember one thing at a time. I had it
create this readme as well. So we have
full instructions for running
everything. So installing it from git
which by the way you can follow this.
You can go through these instructions
yourself to have this superbase MCP
server running yourself which is really
cool. So we built out a full working
example in this video and then you build
the container and then you can set up
the configuration within your cloud
desktop or your winds surf your cursor
whatever just using this as the config
example and that's it like that's all it
takes to get started. So we have this
deployed now you can literally clone
this repo and do it all yourself and
that is our full process. We literally
went from start to finish with this
document. Ideation to implementation to
testing to writing out our documentation
all the way to deploying. We took care
of it all. And so that was a lot.
Honestly, this video took a very very
long time to prep and record everything
for you. So I hope that this process was
super helpful for you. And yeah, there
might be certain parts to it that I
would dive into in more details in
another video. Also, I really do want to
make a full video on building a MCP
server from scratch and going into a lot
more detail on that. So, let me know in
the comments if you'd be interested in
that as well. So, I hope that this video
can help you be way more efficient when
coding with AI. And please let me know
in the comments what your process looks
like, too. I'm super curious. I'm sure
there's things that you would want to
add to what I'm doing, or you just have
other things that work really well for
you. So, I'd love to hear it. There
definitely isn't a one-sizefits-all
approach for using these powerful tools.
I just wanted to share what works well
for me. So, if you appreciated this
video and you're looking forward to more
things AI coding and AI agents, I would
really appreciate a like and a
subscribe. And with that, I'll see you
in the next